hello people we are going to watch the
bad batch
episode 7 today so get ready to sync up
with us on disney plus if you are
pledged here to do the watch alongs with
us
a space battle i don't think ruby likes
it very much
you name that thing
what's with these guys well we did steal
from them
technically the rope
oh no get it off get it get it off
you're scaring her yeah
oh no
[Music]
hunter what are you two up to
the mission's over can we go again
it's a tradition it makes the kid happy
aha the kid
don't take long
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're both kids
who is that strider
you said the job paid three times this
for me
not for you rather generous considering
the debt you owe me
what debt docking fees
poor charges gear fuel ratio
did you say talking peace yeah that's
part of the mission
mm-hmm there'll be 14 credits for the
mantel mix
oh yeah put it on stitch time oh
god oh no you're wrecking
their bills
han shot first who are you
[Music]
oh great another clone
just what i needed i'm so ex
i didn't think you'd show up so soon is
this the commander rex i've heard about
it's been a while boys where have you
been rex
[Music]
that's a long story
let me tell you about the finale
imperial files have you listed as killed
in action
being dead in the empire's eyes has its
advantages
well look who it is
come here rex i thought you didn't like
the regs this one we like omega
this is rex i've met many clones in my
time
but never one like you
[Music]
you're a generation one how'd you know
that
from the lines in your face
check dude you gotta have that looked at
you used the last one what's wrong no
dan finally if you're concerned about
the so-called inhibitor chips don't be
you haven't removed your chips no
not yet rex knows how to do it where do
you think i got this head scar
those chips make you a threat to
everyone around you
even her take it easy captain we'll show
them how to remove it
well how do you suggest we get them out
good question
i'll be in touch
[Laughter]
good thing rex found you guys there's a
chance for wrecker
i i don't like this plan he wants to cut
over my head
all of our heads actually not mine i
don't have an inhibitor chip why not
that's not fair give her a chip if you
cut it open anyway
i'm picking up rex's beacon
wow
god that's such good animation
oh man raqqa may not be much to look at
but it has exactly what we need i had my
inhibited chip taken out oh
wow that's where we're heading then why
don't we land all the way over here
everyone down that's why
need to keep out aside from their
patrols they really capture that like
old
map painting look
and the animation is breathtaking
amazing amazing
it's like a ps5 game
[Music]
what is it stay above the water line
even the water looks great
how'd you get yours out i
had help
medical bays at the other end wreck it
grab that cable you know who helped him
awesome
but she's not coming this is not gonna
happen never nicely done
you're up wrecker uh yeah my head
doesn't hurt anymore
i'm fine oh buddy come on
look at that focus
it's like the descent oh no
oh boy
of course this would happen to him are
you all right
now smells awful down here
[Music]
start climbing why oh hi
oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
tasty sarlacc this will do nicely
i would no longer call this medical bay
a sterile environment
do you prefer to use the facility on
camino
this will do nicely time to get scanned
wrecker
let's get this over with
this thing better not activate like a
minute before uh
a little afraid it's gonna or that
messing with it will cause it to kick
in
[Music]
i think i found something
get that away from me
[Music]
let's hope the scrappers don't come
around we couldn't save the general but
last we helped the padawan
order 66. wired are yours guys
you just gotta get him unconscious for a
minute whack him on the head
oh nice knife to a gunfight
oh god outer
hit him again ah let's snap out of it
[Music]
no
keep moving omega
climb into the tube
this isn't you wrecker it's the
inhibitor chip
i don't want to hurt you
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
i'll do it the procedure's complete
wrecker wrecker he should be awake by
now
he is live we won't know more until he
regains consciousness
why don't you take a make a top side and
get some air
no i'm staying until he wakes
up oh
hey kid he's awake oh
you made it one chip down three to go
who's next you should just keep
abducting clothes
just keep kidnapping them taking them
here make your own free thinking army
they have built an
army rebuild it listen
oh my god oh buddy i tried to control it
i tried as hard as i could i know rika
it's okay
the mission's over can't break tradition
thanks kids
look how terrible this animation it's
yeah geez
for children i figured you went out of
the fight who was you talking to are you
talking to a soccer
the republic's going rex ah
not all of it we're here others are out
there too
there'll be a new republic stay out of
trouble
funny i was going to say the same to you
we're clones take care trooper
that is certainly not the last we'll see
of him in this
if you're ever ship buy it you know how
to reach us
[Music]
no damn intruders confirmed on the jedi
cruiser
notify the empire no
it looks like we're getting to the meat
and potatoes of things now huh
take on the whole empire next episode
all right that was awesome stuff that
was really awesome stuff man
i wish more people would be watching
this show because there's a lot of great
tie-ins too
the other famous animated shows from
star wars
especially i didn't think we'd see rex
so soon so i guess the confirmation is
that the contact was indeed not ahsoka
uh that the ortez sisters were talking
to last week that it was
rex and they must have repaired r7
amazon this one must be what it is
stands for reason in this case but yeah
i mean rex is
like my favorite so i was just so
excited to see him here
and there's so many great like
some of the themes seem to be
communicated just through the mood alone
and that's what i really appreciate
about this episode like there's this one
moment where i'm not sure if it's in the
highlights or not but uh
there's just one moment where rex is
like
looking ominously amongst his uh clone
helmet
after wreckers had a surgery and
it's like you just imagine all the kind
of thoughts are probably going through
his head
of what times used to be like what it
meant to don
this outfit he's got the the markings uh
the
the count on his inside of his helmet
yeah and
just like there was such a sense of
pride before
and nostalgic memories that come to mind
but now that's sort of been like
tainted with because of what has
happened with the empire
and order 66 wants to become of the
clones
and it was neat bringing them back and
it's like he kind of does just show up
at like the most convenient [ __ ] time
in the world
you know um you're right boys chip's
gonna activate pretty s any second now
good thing
rex showed up yeah what would happen if
he didn't i mean rex would have just
turned
as demonstrated in this episode and
yeah it was out of any clone or any
person really it would that would be the
soca or
rex who would be the one to show up
considering the events of clone wars
of how rex had his chip activated for a
while before ahsoka was able to
do the process herself of deactivating
it so
yeah for him to come in here and sort of
have a
i don't think he's in like a need of
redemption but it is neat to see him go
on the other side considering how
he was in the position before where he
was in one attack and had to go on
how to undergo it but now he's able to
help out you know some more of his
brothers
by being able to go through with this
but more importantly that like the
episode itself was just a wonderful
emotional piece in so many ways that
seemed to
kind of riff off the first lord of the
rings movie yeah a lot of the lord of
the rings and then
obviously alien later on but yeah
especially in the bar
and then in the uh or the little cantina
there and then with the
uh octopus creature i don't know that
octopus
is it's not a sarlacc but yeah it
definitely harkened back to lord of the
rings i thought they
had a just so much really wonderful
atmosphere
and in both in terms of like the just
the physical landscapes and we comment
on the actual the animation and all that
stuff and just like you know the
fog in the water and these vast expanses
but also
yeah just this aura it's like some of
the episodes have
uh seemingly quicker plotting or quicker
pacing or something about it
that you know makes it feel sort of like
very plot oriented whereas this episode
still has that but at the same time it
had like this air
around it that contributed to the sense
of foreboding and to the tension
overall because it's like even though
you're in this big deserted place and
yeah we've got a couple people to look
out for
it does feel like way more
claustrophobic than it ought to and i
feel like that's
you know really a credit to how
evocative they're able to play some of
these scenes and when the show leans
more into being physical
and into being sort of sensory like they
can this was another episode that got me
thinking like you know
this feels sort of uh more cinematic
than
usual and not like it's aimed for like
you know kids or something but just
anybody um
and yeah i don't know it gave like all
the
all the it's like we're expecting record
a turn at some point
you know he's obviously the one they've
set up to show what can go wrong
for our team in this scenario but even
that i thought they rung some nice
tension out of him when he's going after
omega like
even though you know nothing too bad is
gonna happen there it was a really
effective sequence
yes well there was this was the most
emotional we've seen the bad batch in
total i mean right down to the
fear in hunter's eyes when he's being
choked out by
wrecker you're really seeing the terror
that can come from one of your own
like they had the experience of
crosshairs but they didn't really have
as much of an understanding of what was
going on you know
yeah they didn't really grasp the
gravity of the situation here at hand
and then to see with record that like
hey just a minute ago you were
completely you you were you were one of
us and then
in a second it's like a terminator
switch has just gone off in you
and it literally was just the terror
that they were all experiencing
this is not our brother anymore this is
someone else
and having to deal with that was was a
real intense situation at hand
uh and i i love that the reason i love
this episode
so much it's like this and the first
episode are my favorites because
because it's like the turning of events
with your people within your team the
ones the few who you can trust
it's it's personal because
this is an inter-intertwining inner
working situation with our main
characters it's not about like doing
some
fun mission or something like that yeah
this is dealing with one of our own it's
a life-and-death situation
it's very personal and i love that about
it and uh
and really capturing the hearts it's
been like really charming and
and cute and there was like a really
great moment a couple episodes ago when
wrecker
built a little place for uh omega to
sleep but this right here got me
like missy eyed at just the bun and
uh how they confide in one another and
there is this like
older brother situation that's happening
between it's like hunter is more of like
the father to omega yeah and then
wrecker is like the cool uncle or older
brother to omega like there's a real
kinship between the two which i really
love a lot that was
so demonstrated was uh um wonderfully in
this uh in this episode like literally
it's a it there's a bit of a mood piece
vibe to it
and i think the planet
was the one from jedi fallen order where
calcas is first working at the beginning
it's really dark at the beginning of
jedi fallen order
but if you're a true fan you can see
through that
i mean i don't remember the name of the
planet but i i
think that's what the planet is and
yeah so i mean it just goes to add on to
more of the world building but
i do love the sort of the patience that
this episode struck
of yes is it convenient that rex shows
up at just the right time sure
uh but i i love how like yeah in order
to do the surgery we got to travel
really freaking far and then we got to
sneak in there
and go through this hurdle that kind of
makes you think of the movie the descent
you know having to deal with like going
through the wreckage
and then hopefully the surgery will go
well you
was all of this yeah and there's no
guarantee even of that
yeah it was as a harrowing situation to
thrust these characters
into that i've this
i'm really feeling the stakes truly
being felt like that i think the show
show's really been coming into its own a
lot more lately they can just keep up
with this like tone
mood here this is more of what i really
love especially with a bad batch this is
more of like the first episode i think
like nailed the just the perfect tone
and then when you cinematically hone in
on the darkness of the situation they're
at like you can feel
of there's like ident
so much of what this epi these episodes
seem to deal with is this theme of
identity and where do i belong
in the galaxy i once i was designed for
a specific purpose but now that purpose
is
to be part of the evil side of the
galaxy where do i really fit in and
where do i belong you know like even
hunter being like i gotta do what's best
for my team
i don't know what that is but i gotta do
it
you know i gotta figure it out and then
even like rex having to deal with uh
there's so much history with rex
uh like him talking ab i i actually love
the way that was
handled in the beginning of you still
have your chips and he was afraid
because yes that's right like clone wars
ended with having to
uh like with ahsoka and rex and all the
stone trooper helmets just
you know stacked there they had to bury
a lot of their own
and it's for rex this is a heartbreaking
situation you know he was a leader
like he was a high ranking officer here
he was uh yeah that's the right term
i think so whatever i'm not good with
the terminology he's a higher
he's hiring knows captain rex if you've
seen clone wars and he does show up in
rubble so you do know his fate that he's
gonna be fine
um but him being here i like this
transitional period because it ends with
rex and clone wars and then you catch up
to him when he's like an old man he's
all grayed out
by the time you get to him in rebels so
seeing like
kind of the in between of what led to
there of the rise of the resistance and
the rise of the rebellion against the
empire
and it just seems like that's where the
bad batch is headed towards is joining
up with them you know
because they're right now they're still
in this rogue area so
the this i i'm starting to really get a
sense for what this show is doing that's
different than the other
two where they are they seem like they
are
doing a lot to fill in the blanks and
the gaps
between the shows rebels and clone wars
but they do that all through keeping it
solely focused on the bad
batch and their journey which i think is
kind of neat
clone wars you would hop around
characters for stretches a period of
time
rebels would do that but wasn't reliant
on it and like they focused on their
core team and yes other characters did
show up from clone wars but here this
really seems to be
doing all it and mandalorian included
with like fennec shan and the guild and
all that so
yeah i thought this was uh oh there's a
a great episode and
because here's the thing to cap it off
on my point
wrecker generally even has been like
badass and like yeah you saved the day
or really funny
yeah you know and i thought he's like
the uncle on the team so i'm like oh you
know like i don't want you to turn
and to have a moment like that with him
and omega at the end that was so
beautiful
was like i'm really taking this wrecker
scene serious
yeah i'm not laughing at this at all and
it was actually kind of refreshing to
get that for
a record dialogue scene yeah yeah yeah
because it really plays
like an actual moment between two people
who have just had an intense experience
and who
are you know probably reluctant for
various reasons to even have this
interaction but
so yeah that love that bond prevails
like yeah
it it i hadn't even thought about it but
you're right it is like
a legitimate emotional scene about
wrecker and omega and uh yeah that's
that's good that's props to them for
doing that because i usually do
associated with just being like the fun
characters yeah
and i think out of all the guest stars
from the other shows
uh or or the additional part like yes i
know they factor in more just the star
wars lore and galaxy and all that but
rex we mainly know from clone wars to
out of all the guest stars from the
other shows
this was the most utilized the most
effective one i thought
to really capitalize on the heart of it
all uh yeah
that was uh i i really quite enjoyed i
know a lot of people don't watch our
reactions
for before this and there can be that
little thing because these take a lot of
time and work to put together
uh they do just like anyone who does
reactions for this that takes a lot of
time
and the part of my brain does go off of
like
do we really want to cover this right
now because it seems like not a lot of
people are that interested in
specifically our reactions and um
you know it always affects the algorithm
when you have a low performing video
so it's that it's that thing of like
should we cover this but whenever we
watch it i'm like i'm glad we're
covering this yeah
this is like another reminder of yeah
you know it doesn't do great in views
for us
specifically there are other channels
who are doing great with it but not us
in particular and you know whatever
reason that is
fine but on on my personal end i really
do enjoy watching this show a lot
i hate it and i don't want to be and
that's why people don't watch it
i don't know maybe i mean i enjoyed the
show quite a bit
and it only gives me more desire to then
continue
you know making myself more and more
familiar with stuff like clone wars and
the other things that aren't just the
movies that everybody knows so
so yeah i mean and and it too yeah like
it is
a fun expanding experience for me and
for somebody who
watched this episode being aware of who
captain rex is but not really
knowing who captain rex is i thought
they did a nice job of communicating
just what that character means and what
his and giving him a sense of presence
you know to kind of reach people like me
well yeah it's it's interesting what
this show's doing because it's so
it's it seems like you really need to be
familiar with clone wars
and you need to have some familiarity
with the rebels
you know and like obviously mandalorian
too with the fennec shantines and
whatever else may come but
um yeah this one is this show for a new
series is like no you're
we're honing in on the fan base of the
people who watch the shows
so i could see how if you're if you
haven't seen them
how audiences might actually drop off of
this show
because it seems to really rely on you
you haven't been invested in those other
ones you know yeah and and being that
they come out in such bite-sized
packages too i feel like you have to
have that investment
yeah it's fascinating fascinating choice
but at the same time it's like it would
kind of be annoying if it was just like
expositional recaps for every [ __ ]
time a new character
a familiar character showed up yeah yeah
well and i
i don't know i mean i feel like it is
kind of neat when they do that because
they still
seem to incorporate the characters in a
way that works for the linear
progression of
this immediate story but also then is
way richer if you understand
the other history surrounding the
character they don't
alienate you by you know making it clear
like we only care about the people who
know this guy
yeah yeah yeah it just it's obviously
it's obviously the experience would be
much more rewarding if you are
familiar with those other shows anywho
guys what'd you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below do you
want more
wrecks i'm actually glad they went with
rex instead of ahsoka
yeah i gotta say that too i mean yeah in
my own
uninformed opinion it does actually make
a lot of sense to me and especially if
she was the one responsible for
alleviating that for him for him then to
go out and to pass it on and to pass it
on to his own
is more meaningful i think exactly yeah
like this whole thing about him standing
there going i don't know i've
i've never seen the process from this
side i know it worked on me but i'm just
kind of here to
help as much as i can yeah yeah it made
it
very relatable in that moment guys leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
the notification bell
hit that like button and uh
yeah we will catch you guys soon
see you guys